CONSECUTIVE 6-3 SETBACKS IN
VANCOUVER
EDMONTON HAS TAKEN A 1-0 LEAD!K.
JAMS IT HOME ON THE SHORT SIDE.
GILLIES STILL DOESN'T KNOW WHERE
IT  BREAKAWAY, FOEGELE!
HE'S ABLE TO SQUEEZE THE FIVE
HOLE SHUT JUST IN T SPLAYED OUTT
BRATT, THAT'S HIS 20TH OF THE  .
HAND, FOREHAND, TUCKS I I
OF THE PUCK, YOU DON'T NORMALLY
SEE LATER IN THE
>> Jack: SHARANGOVICH, GLOVE.
THAT'S SETTLED FOR DUNCAN KEITH
McDAVID.
HE RECOGNIZES IT'S HISCHIER.
HE SAYS, I'M GOING WRAP THIS
JUST A GOOD PASSING PLAY.
EVERYBODY TOUCHED THAT PUCK ON
THE SEQUENCE.
HE TAKES IT
ECT.FOEGELE.
COUPLE OF EX-CANES.
SHORE. SHORE THAT'S UP
HIGH, GIVES HIMSELF AN OPTION,
PUTS HIS
STUTTER STEP.
TYSON BARRIE.
McDAVID
THIS IS A PASS THAT WAS PUT
ACROSS INTURY NET.
GET BODIES IN FRONT OF A
6-3 EDMONTON!